hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1857 first
American chess congress in a ford game
between theodore littenheim and paul
charles murphy now in the third game
littenheim was the first person in this
tournament to put a crack in Murphy's
armor he he managed to grab a draw but I
have something to apologize to her
friends and at the bar in the library
for even though we said the game ended
where it did after 31 moves were played
that more if you didn't want to grind it
out that's actually not correct more if
he tried to grind it out for 24 more
moves and the game lasted up until 55
moves but those moves were not published
so only 31 move was published and that's
what we've seen so we don't have what
happened after that but the game still
stands that those moves were played and
it was a draw and like I said this is a
game for our listener and saw that he he
could have a better game against Murphy
if he doesn't go for an open open game
or a semi open game he definitely wants
to play a closed game so in the previous
game he tried to go for d4 and we went
into that Queens gambit declined but
here
Lytton Hein again goes for d4 but Murphy
now replies with f5 he goes for the
Dutch and okay Knight c3 we have Knight
of 6 with Bishop to g5 & e6 and here
liftin Hein again finds a way to keep to
keep it close to exchange as many pieces
as possible and to just try a Sloman
maneuvering game against morphe he goes
for efore we have F captures Knight
captures and now although in those days
even f3 was was an idea Knight captures
only four with Bishop to e7 and now
again a trade Bishop captures Bishop
captures and Queen to h5 Morphy blocks
we have g6 and now Knight captures on f6
width check Queen captures and Queen e5
and with this idea it's only moved nine
but lignan already traded a pair of
knights of progressives and now he wants
to trade Queens and more if he says okay
let's do it
Queen captures pawn captures and b6 now
morphe prepares to fianchetto his
LightSquared Bishop and
the material is equal but it's a
question will the e5 pawn be a strength
or will the e5 pawn be a weakness so
let's see what happens there there are a
couple of games of the database of
modern games where Bishop to e2 was
played but here listen Hine goes for
castles Queen side and it is as a move
xi at this position has never been
reached again more if he continues with
the well development Bishop e7
I think it was the light square Bishop
and now not wanting to go for a knight
to f3 tell out the doubling of the
points of first and Knight to h3 and
also if the e5 pawn comes under siege
we're gonna defend it with f4 we have
rook the f8 putting pressure on the pawn
now if the knight moves so rook the g1
getting the rook out of this nasty
diagonal and now Knight to c6 developing
and attacking the pawn here with f4
defending it the night from h3 now
nicely supports the pawn and Morphy that
to really get his pieces into play he
wants the he has to play these sex do
something about this week upon and he
has to get his rook into the game maybe
with King g7 and getting the rook into
the game that way so he starts with it
right away
King g7 and now g3 now the F pawn is
nicely defended so the knight can now
hopefully get into the game and now more
if he goes for a d6 he wants to bust
open the position here and maybe even
win a pawn so better up to g2 not
allowing it now the pony's defended
indirectly because of Bishop captures
and unbe 7 if the knight ever moves D
captures an e that's a knight sorry D
captures an e5 f captures an e5 and now
of course you cannot capture because the
bishop would hang so rook the f5 you go
after the e5 pawn this way so
rook the g1 littenheim defends it and
now rook to d8 Morphy interested in
trading
further trading pieces with g4 elite
anion kicks away more fees rook from the
attack of the pawn here and now rook
captures on d1 saying okay if you
capture with the rook then I grab the
point so King captures pretty much only
move and now the rook has to move so
ruku goes back again if you capture just
the rook captures Knight captures and
again you hang the bishop on b7 so look
back
fate and now a lift and hind doesn't
know how to how to develop without
leaving the defense of the e5 pawn
because as long as as long as it's there
it's a weak point and well more he might
be able to win it so here he decides to
play Bishop captures on c6 he eliminates
the night which leaves the morphe with a
bishop against tonight but it's a light
square Bishop ended the ponies on a dark
square so least a nine says this is now
this is now definitely a good idea so
with king d2 and now h6 by morphe taking
away the g5 square from Leighton Hines
Knight rook to e3 now a nice rook lift
defending the the third-ranked also may
be preventing ideas like rook to f3 and
g5 buy more if you're taking away the f4
square from the night as well with b3
and now rook the f1 now with ideas of
undermining the the second-ranked from
behind rook to e1 of course leaf design
doesn't allow that and here more feet
raised rope capture screen captures and
Bishop the e4 attacking the pawn here
leave behind defense at King D 2 and now
King d7 if you go for the pawn here just
night f2 defends the g4 points so it's
not a problem so we have king to d7
Murphy now starts to bring the King into
the game and now see for getting rid of
the weakness king c6 and now Knight the
f2 attacking the bishop and Bishop to be
won and here liftin hind goes for
Knights to d1 again a similar similar
idea we've seen in official versus
Spassky the the legendary poisoned pawn
here liftin Hein offers the a to pawn
but in return he will trap the Bishop
Buddhist King and well instead of going
back with more with Bishop to e4 Morphy
like Fischer grabs the pawn bishop
character Sunday - and ok late tonight
says ok King c2 we're gonna grab that
Bishop with King c5 by morphe and not
Knight to c3 going after the bishop so
you can't do anything about it you pick
up yet another pawn so Bishop captures
nb3
King captures in the now c6 taking away
these two squares from
tonight and here night Stewie to Rima
nuvaring the night but it is also that
unmoved 34 we do not have the rest the
rest of the game now
the score shows that more if you won
this game and indeed he won the match
after winning this game
but it's hard it's hard to know it's
hard to read it even consider how this
game went on now I will show and maybe
uh maybe a way of how the game could
have continued but for black to actually
win this white definitely needed to make
a serious blunder because like in the
previous game more if he tried to grind
it out but littenheim defended properly
but here it says that littenheim lost
and he well he definitely blunder
somewhere yeah because he's up a night
okay more fees more fees up to two
points but you know a night is a night
as Taiwan said but what could have
happened here is something like be five
more she would definitely want to create
two connected task points on the Queen
side let's say characters captures
nights to see three back and now a five
and it's those two pawns are extremely
strong and at some point black will have
to give up the night for example if you
try something like h3a for a for width
check King III King C for kicking away
the knight Knight to e2 and now King D
five you want to go after back after the
pawn and now we would either see a
repetition Knight c3 came back to c4 or
we would go into maybe a further game
with King captures Knight captures here
and now you go after these pawns and
also you might consider pushing despawn
but at this point but whatever you
choose it's it's a very hard to imagine
that that lift and haven't lost the game
for example Knight c3 c5 you're gonna
grab the pawn you're gonna go
efore king before white of course wants
to get get back into the game III King
c4 King g3 now you go after the pawns
now nice efore check King f4 and now
after King d3 for example if the King
now finally arrives e to you force the
King to capture because you get a queen
into the game so after captures captures
it's a it's a drone end game king of two
King a for King G
zucchini three shaking g3u again grab a
position kinky to Kingi to King III King
g3 and so on so that's one of the one of
the possibilities after this night to
eat too but something like b5 and the
creating two pawns on the Queen side
probably what happened but it's hard to
say but yeah morphe wins the third match
in the first American chess congress so
against Thompson three to zero against
meat three to zero and now against
Theodore least and hind three and a half
to half which is which is much better
than than the others and Paulson also
defeated his opponent Raphael with wit
would I believe with the same score
three and a half to half he also got one
draw against the Polson and I would just
like to as now we're continuing with the
final so the first American chess
Congress Paul Morphy vs. Louis Paulsen
and I would just like to read to you a
small part from Lawson's book at the
create it does create a little bit of a
hype for the finals if you don't mind so
he says on October 26th more both Morphy
and Paulsen Warren the third games of
their respective opponents and so
advanced that a final test for the first
prize now the two most formidable
players of the Congress were to face
each other
Paulsen and Murphy were in most striking
contrast physically mentally and
temperamentally Paulson was a blonde
Nordic large in frame cautious and
phlegmatic more feet dark hair and dark
eyed short in stature and quick and
reactions combinations in play but they
were much alike in modesty and courtesy
and each had stirred the Congress to
heights of enthusiasm and expectation
morphe would have revealed the mastery
of the chessboard and Paulsen with his
clairvoyant power to use his own word in
speaking of his blindfold chess playing
both were eager for the final contest so
we're gonna we're gonna have a great
time with the finals of the first
American chess congress between morphe
and paulson so that that's where we're
going from here but yeah like I said
like you've seen elite and I got a
better result than Mick or Thompson
because he in the last two games played
close positions against morphe he didn't
go for some crazy for
gambits or something like that where
morphe really thrives he tried for in
the third game with the Queens gambit
declined and here okay more he won for
the Dutch but there wasn't a lot to work
with so that's that's how we want to
play against against morphe but as we
can see here even though he he took it
all the way to a drone endgame in game
he couldn't hold the draw against
morphine although for some reason I
decided not to publish the rest of the
game at this game or or the previous one
I guess it wasn't that exciting so they
didn't wanna wait waste paper or I don't
know but yeah that's it I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank [ __ ]
[ __ ] james thurber abraham ryan
schneider hector Coronado and Cody
Holden for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - all my previous
videos here and thank all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing with
the morphe saga continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and of
course whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day